pour en parler nous sommes avec jean
vincent brisset directeur de recherche à
l'iris et spécialiste de la chine merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation alors
la justice américaine affirme que la
directrice financière de huawei aurait
reconnu avoir menti sur les activités de
son groupe en iron ore du côté de la
chine on soutient qu'elle aurait plaidé
non-coupable comment expliquer ces deux
versions contradictoires
alors je pense que tous les côtés il y
avait une volonté d' arrêter cette
mascarade qui durait depuis pas mal
d'années donc il ya comme l'a fait la
justice américaine très très volontiers
et la justice anglo saxonne en général
il ya un accord qui intervient le chacun
repart avec cinq versions et chacun à
les libérer en échange de quelque chose
d'autre alors selon vous est-ce qu'il
s'agit d'une histoire purement
politiques comme le prétend le
gouvernement chinois
je crois que c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué que ça parce que on est dans
une affaire triangulaire entre le canada
les états unis et la chine pour les
états unis on était en état dans la
sortie de cet affrontement très
bilatérale qui caractérise l
administration trump on passe à quelque
chose d'un petit peu différent dans le
style le propre des problèmes aussi du
canada et de la chine il ya eu des
problèmes latéraux liés à un gang lié à
beaucoup à beaucoup d'autres d'autres
choses et le canada grosses faiblesses
sa vie de la chine pendant quelques
temps puis a pris position beaucoup plus
dur avec en particulier des critiques
assez violente contre le gouvernement
chinois par des groupes des associations
quelle suite selon vous cette affaire
pourrait elle encore
donné
pour le moment je pense qu'on se dirige
vers une sorte d'apaisement madame
mangwa jo va retourner en chine et va
reprendre je pense avec son avec sa
famille la direction de rwe le canada va
récupérer ses deux ces deux détenus qui
ont quand même beaucoup souffert et qui
ont été traitées toute manière tout à
fait différente mais là - gwangju était
retenu au canada dans une villa luxueuse
où étaient libres de ce mouvement alors
que les deux yeux les deux canadiens
étaient elles dans une prison où ce
n'était pas vraiment la même qualité de
vie on va arrêter d'en parler je pense
qu'on a un certain temps ça ne résout
pas les problèmes fairway les états unis
en particulier
alors qu'en est il des relations entre
le canada et la chine maintenant est-ce
qu'elle pourrait se réchauffer désormais
après la résolution de cette affaire
vieille de trois ans maintenant
se réchauffer je ne sais pas dans la
mesure où le canada a besoin de ses
exportations vers la chine elle avait
largement chuté est ce que la chine va
accepter d'importer de nouveau un peu
plus de choses du canada où est-ce que
ça va continuer comme ça se passe à
l'heure actuelle il faut voir aussi tout
ça c'est lié à quelque chose de plus
large qui le commonwealth et la fin de
hong kong en tant que l'espace de
liberté aux portes de la chine dans
lequel le canada était largement
appliquée alors huawei est accusée
d'espionnage de la part des etats-unis
où est ce qu'en font ses accusations est
ce que ça s'est résolu ou est ce qu elle
tiennent encore le coup c'est les
accusations d'espionnage
bon les accusations d'espionnage ça a
conduit à des blocages d'équipement où
on voyait qu'ils ont pas pu être ont pas
pu être exportées et qui n'ont pas pu
être implantés dans le monde occidental
à l'heure actuelle
donc ils vont sans doute continuer de
bloquer ça c'est autre chose qui va
pouvoir se dérouler l'espionnage par
huawei s'est maintenant c'est terminé
l'accusation a été portée les
interdictions ont été menées et le reste
va continuer je pense sans huawei 100
implantations derouet dans un certain
nombre des pays occidentaux qui en sort
vainqueur de ce de cet accord conclu
entre huawei et les autorités
américaines
alors je pense pas qu'on puisse parler
de vainqueurs ou des vaincus je pense
tout simplement on a maintenant on a
officialisé un statu quo huawei n'aura
pas la liberté de déployer ces matériels
ont pas pour la 5g de continuer à
déployer ces normes dans une grande
partie de l'occident parce que c'est
quelque chose qui était refusé par
beaucoup d'autres pays que les etats
unis jean vincent brisset merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes directeur de recherche à
l'iris et spécialiste de la chine